oh
[Applaudissements]
pas idéal jacques entre son journal pour
gérer l'hôtel
j'espère qu'elle se trouve ça super
braillard grande portable n'a fait mal
aux images sont putty des ptic romera le
petit écho de la forêt c'est très serré
vous la verrez il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception
ça vous le découvrirez dans le tue des
cours d'eau fort
sheikh téléphone voyons les faits divers
au coq très amusant louis le renard
remet sa maison à 9
ce qui m'étonne car notre ami louis
n'est pas très courage et voilà qu'il
entreprend de gros travaux aurait-il
d'en changer
mais si je fais tous ces travaux je vais
être épuisées exténué il faut que je
trouve quelqu'un d'aller faire de place
j'ai une idée je suis rue et luis euros
d'isf et les frères casto bénoué dois je
m'en sortirai bien tout ce ménage avait
posé une voiture louis vient d'apprendre
à tout seul et la peinture demande un
bon coup de pinceau bien j'en prendrais
tout cela est possible mais pourquoi
avez vous un milieu avait fui c'est
affreux
donc tu ne peux pas réparé est à toi tu
évites acheminer cet affreux mais pour
perdre il faut savoir mélanger découlent
tu as déjà essayé j'aime cet affreux
m'abuse on va tomber en ruine ne
t'inquiète pas les deux bains keyyo mais
moi ne vient de donner un coup de main
je ne voudrais pas buzzé
dans la vie il faut savoir s'entraider
ou que je suis rusé d'idiomes et edward
sûrs qu'une surprise en arrivant chez
leurs amis aux eaux que je sauve que je
sors mon pauvre louis
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive je suis
brûlé les deux pattes en voulant vous
préparez un petit des jeux du monde
quel malheur quel mal je voudrais bien
vous aider à refaire ma maison je ne
peux plus rien faire avec mes deux packs
bande des méfaits nous confiance on ne
doit jamais abandonné 1
merci merci merci j'ai réussi ils vont
faire tout le travail que je suis reçue
je suis encore plus rusé que je le
pensais il est deux frères k stores
entreprirent les réparations que
souhaitait lui le renard que penses tu
de cette porte que certains vers sata
plages de rêve john a oui mais je ne
voudrais pas un but 14 du désert doit ce
que j'ai mise sur toi mon boulot il a ta
place je revis des tuiles ah oui je ne
voudrais pas abuser quelques jours plus
tard la maison de louis le rusé
paraissait comme neuf et les deux frères
castor est épuisé vous aurez bien faire
à manger à symbolique mais valeureuse je
ne peux pas bouger plus regardant le
garde-manger inquiète par man band oui
allez nous allons vite à faire des
provisions
ici et que je surveillais edwards
guillaume ne vous dérangez pas souhaité
apporter tout ce qui faut pas vous
régaler au lieu de minutes le pique
nique fut installé sur le gazon et les
deux frères k stores comment certains se
restaurer sous l'oeil à sam et de l'ouïe
de ruser moment louis un peu de fromage
il ne peut pas manger c'est très mauvais
attendant les biens brûlés n'est ce pas
louis la risée boxe comme ans abusée à
une belle grappe de raisin bien mûres
mon bon louis voulait la tuer
c'est très mauvais quand on a les mains
brûlées n'est ce pas non il
max continue buzy en même pas un petit
verre de second but ferait pas question
tout le monde sait que j'ai horreur
d'abuser qui devient enfin raisonnable
figure toi mon pauvre louis que je
croyais que tu avais fait semblant
d'avoir les mains brûlées pour ne pas
travailler moi ça m'est cher louis et te
croyais pur lui le renard quand il fut
seul se jeta sur les restes du repas il
mange à toutes étant qu'il fut vraiment
malade
cette fois encore il avait abusé on est
toujours puni par où on a péché n'est ce
poste cherté des femmes
à bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt
[Musique]